captain francis pike leads his team
across the arctic tundra in the distance
they can see the city of
autopapadopoulos
it flows 7.8 kilometers above the ground
and is filled with mysteries and
treasures beyond even the foundation's
wildest dreams
it is september of 1933 when the scp
foundation first catches winds of
something odd going on in the arctic a
british airman named sir george danson
flies over the north sea heading to
norway after he lands in oslo danson
begins ranting about a floating city the
foundation immediately disseminates
contradictory information and
manipulates the story to include that
danson had been drinking during his
flight so everything he is saying is
probably the result of a drunken
hallucination while scp agents spread
lies the foundation immediately launches
an investigation the team that is sent
to the arctic confirms what danson
claims to have seen there is indeed a
floating city there now captain pike and
his team stare at the island in the sky
as their hot air balloons are filled
behind them the arctic wind whips up
small snow tornadoes as the temperature
plummets the balloons are ready and pike
orders his men to board they lift off
from the ground and pull their parka
hoods over their heads to protect them
from the arctic blasts at high altitudes
pike and his team slowly drift over the
city of autopapadopoulos when they are
somewhat in the middle of the floating
island the hot air balloons are lowered
and the team lands without incident to
their surprise the exploratory team
finds that the floating city has its own
microclimate which is much more pleasant
than the frigid arctic they remove their
winter gear proceed with caution pike
tells his men we have no idea what we're
going to find in the city the
architecture is clearly old but not
exactly like anything on earth today it
seems to be a conglomerate of ancient
mesopotamian design mixed with the
design features of several other
cultures many of the buildings that line
the stone streets are crumbling and the
city overall is in ruins pike leads his
team down a series of roads scientists
photograph and take notes of the city
for foundation records scp agents check
around every corner to make sure there
is nothing hiding in the shadows the
team comes to a crossroads halt bike
shouts standing in front of them is an
old man with long gray hair and a white
beard he seems to be of middle eastern
descent hello friends the old man says
welcome to ariba padopoulos i am the
caretaker of the city i've been
expecting you please follow me the old
man turns around and proceeds down the
causeway pike hesitates for a moment
stay alert he whispers to the agents
behind him then he begins to follow the
old man down the street as pike walks he
takes in the grandeur that the city once
held the roads are as wide as the main
avenues back in london while the
buildings although in shambles still
retains some of their ancient beauty
pike begins to walk a little faster to
catch up with the old man what happened
here he asks the man turns his head all
will be revealed soon francis pike just
be patient how do you know my name asks
spike the old man smiles they turn
another corner and in front of them is
the grand hall it seems to have survived
whatever catastrophe befell the rest of
the city pike stops and stares up at the
massive structure with his mouth ajar
come says the old man as he motions the
scp team to follow him up the steps into
the main hall let's eat the old man
prepares a simple meal but one that
fills the stomachs and satisfies pyke
and his men at the conclusion of the
meal captain pike approaches the
mysterious man i feel like you deserve
an explanation as to who we are and why
we're here pike says the old man raises
his hand you are from the foundation he
replies i already know about the
foundation and you french's pike i have
been waiting for you to arrive for a
long time there are things i need to
show you in the city there are old
secrets and ancient relics from the past
that you were sent here to learn about
pike looks at the men in squints what
are you talking about how could you know
we were coming and what relics are you
referring to exactly the old man grins
and places a hand on captain pike's
shoulder pike feels a longing emotion
well up inside of him it's as if he has
been waiting for this moment his whole
life come says the old man you and your
man need rest he shows pike and the
exploration team to several rooms down
the hallway where they can set up for
the night the rooms are large and
comfortable sleep well french's pike
tomorrow i have much to show you the old
man leaves the room and proceeds down
the hallway to his small humble chamber
the next morning pike and the other scp
agents are greeted by the rising sun and
the old man waiting for them on the
steps of the grand hall he leads them
through the city there are three temples
i wish to show you the old man says to
pike you will notice that their
architecture and imagery differ from
most of the other structures in the city
make sure you listen very carefully
frances pike as what you're about to
learn could save the universe or perhaps
destroy it pike is speechless all he can
do is nod his head the old man leads the
scp agents to the middle of the city
where the three temples reside each one
has its own unique iconography and style
the art seems to reflect important
events in history or subjects that hold
significance in the past the old man
proceeds to walk towards the first
temple upon entering the structure there
is a mural of two naked people watching
the horizon from a tree line behind them
are a wolf and bear that seem to be
protectively standing guard directly
opposite of this picture is a painting
of a figure holding a flaming sword on a
hill as pike and his team enter the main
hall they are welcomed by a gigantic
mural depicting the sun rising over
anadapadopoulos
this is where the temple of sunrise gets
its name the old man says gesturing to
the mural on the far wall below the
sunrise is a golden man holding a spear
with a silver point he wears a shining
crown pie can't help but notice that the
man in the mural looks similar to their
guide just a lot younger perhaps it's
his son or a relative pike thinks to
himself above the sunrise is a dragon
with green eyes engraved across the
dragon's body are the words they will
know what is the other walls contain
images of the same golden man in one
picture he stands at the foot of a
throne with a naked woman wrapped in
snakes behind him on another the golden
man sits on the throne with an iron
crown hovering above his head behind him
are monoliths of five figures one is
made of gears and steel another is made
of flesh and blood
the third is made of ice and stone the
fourth is made of stars and the final is
made of eyes the scp agents in the room
begin to buzz with excitement they start
recording everything they see we must
continue on the old man says there isn't
much time left pike nods and orders a
small team to stay behind to continue
documenting the temple of sunrise the
next building they enter is the temple
of sunset within the walls are maps of
different towns and landscapes one of
the maps is adoptadopolis itself the
words the lands of men are scrolled over
the map in the entry hall the old man
stops at the opening to the main gallery
prepare yourself francis pike what you
are about to witness will not be
pleasant they head into the next room
where the temperature immediately shoots
up what the hell is producing all that
heat pike asks there is nothing but
crumbling walls and fallen columns
visible in the room one of the
scientists haulers from the back of the
group jesus sir i think you need to take
a look at this he walks up to pike and
hands him a pair of thermal imaging
goggles pike puts them on damn pike
mutters with the thermal lenses on he
can now see a massive humanoid entity
lying dead on the floor his body is so
large that it covers the murals on three
of the walls pike notices that the
temperature in the room is still
continuing to increase as the dead giant
is radiating heat the foundation
classifies the entity as
scp-4840-b it has six arms and six legs
each connected by metal chains to iron
flails at the end a sigil has been
brandished into the middle of the
entity's chest what is that pike asks
the old man just shakes his head one of
the many who have fallen he responds the
old man points to the only wall that is
not blocked by the massive body of
scp-4840-b and frowns the golden man is
depicted here as well pai can't help but
feel there is some sort of connection
between adudpadopoulos the old man and
the golden figure he keeps seeing in the
murals in the temple of sunset the
golden man sits atop a white horse with
his iron crown resting on his head
behind him is a massive army of men and
women holding axes and swords across
from the golden man and his army are
legions of green and gray figures with
six eyes dressed in brilliantly colored
clothing an intense lightning storm
appears to be amassing in the distance
captain pike looks up to the ceiling to
see it covered in stars however he does
not recognize any of the constellations
is the golden man i keep seeing but
before pike can finish his question the
old man cuts him off we must be going he
turns and exits the temple bike does not
want to push the old man he seems to be
a wealth of knowledge and the only way
to learn more about autodapadopoulos and
what it all means they exit the temple
of sunset and continue to the final
structure in the middle of the city the
old man leads pike and the rest of the
scp agents to the smallest temple of the
three he stops just outside of the
doorway this is the temple of the night
he proclaims what you see on the surface
is deceiving this temple goes deep
underground it contains a labyrinth of
passages that one could get lost in
forever so please be careful are you
coming pike asks no response the old man
i do not enter the temple of night i
have my reasons which do not concern you
pike nods and then signals his men to
follow him into the temple he notices
that many of the murals in the
passageways and rooms of the temple of
night depict the same image of a massive
tree in the middle of a vast forest in
each instance of the tree there seemed
to be red lights surrounding the base
human-like figures hanging from its
branches and structures wrapped in vines
surrounding the trunk the hallways are
illuminated by some unknown light source
it is as if torches line the walls and
give off a dull yellowish glow but there
is no fire to be seen
embedded in the walls are sarcophagi
with intricate carvings in their stone
casings pike can't help but notice
scratching sounds coming from within the
sarcophagi as if someone or something is
trying to claw its way out the
exploration team reaches the innermost
chamber of the temple there is a
staircase in the middle of the room that
descends below the floor however its
entrance is covered by rubble from a
collapsed wall suddenly an scp agent
runs up to captain pike sir i think you
should see this pike follows the man
back through a series of twists and
turns he stops at a closed door the
foundation's seal is carved into the
wood it seems as if the carving has been
there for a long time which is
impossible since they are the first scp
team to explore the city of
otadapadopoulos the agent pushes open
the door and pike steps in he is
astonished by what he finds it seems he
has been transported to an abandoned
foundation site all of the lights are
off but he can tell that it is some kind
of central command center due to the
screens and setup of the space painted
in black block letters on one of the
walls is site site000
pike quickly exits back through the
entryway and shuts the door behind him
he looks at the scp agent who brought
him into the room secure the store and
make sure no one gets in or comes out do
i make myself clear pike orders his men
to exit the temple after everyone comes
out captain pike walks over to the old
man who is sitting on the steps outside
did you find what you are looking for
francis pike the old man asks captain
pike shakes his head he stares down eyes
wide at the stone steps of the temple as
she says the old man i have something
else to show you francis pike the old
man leads pike to the grand hall that
they had slept in the night before he
brings him through a series of
passageways and down a staircase they
stop in front of a large door open it
the old man whispers captain francis
pike walks up to the door and pushes it
open on the other side is endless
darkness from which he hears his own
voice speaking to him through the ether
pike begins to walk towards the darkness
the old man places his hand on pike's
shoulder and pulls him back then he
shuts the door the light of the world
has long since left that place and
mortal men can no longer walk it says
the old man i needed to show it to you
as a warning things are not always what
they seem francis pike that night pike
lies awake staring at the ceiling of the
grand hall thinking about the old man
he sits up and begins jotting down his
thoughts in his official report he
identifies the old man as
scp-4840-a but in his journal he can't
help but refer to him as a friend there
is something about the old man
something special pike knows there is
much more to his story and the story of
the flying city of ottada padopoulos now
watch
scp-001 or a borrow cycle the full story
compilation scp animation or check out
scp-5000 why the full story compilation
scp animation